Ok. I had my. Mask. Three beans.
Universe two cultures.
Sure. Col. James. Fifty seven.
And i work at the university of sydney
and i've been here for about 15 years
still doing a lot of the things
that i did when the pride
of aquarius festival.
I was tutoring here and at the
university new south wales
and was my involvement with sakic just
dudes who were also interested in.
The ideologies that and the protest and
the radical movements of that time.
And who desperately wanted to be involved
in exploring some of those paths
and it was through that university
commitment and the fact
that the aquarius festival was a straight
and union of students event that we
could quite legitimately get involved
and i was capable because i worked also
in new south wales of involving the
students architecture
students at both universities
and they were very keen i must say
i didn't have to do too much.
Coercing and there was a solid group
of students from new south wales
and from sydney who got
involved in the planning
and in the construction of some of
the facilities for the festival
but prior to that though i can recall
very early in the piece maybe a year
or two year
and a half perhaps before the festival
started being approached by johnny allen
dunston. And i can recall
my first meeting with them.
I knew john anyway from the
yellow house of kings cross
but i we had a meeting at my office at
the time which was in the bakery at.
Thing to. And we were
talking about the festival
and how it might be set up
and where it might be set up
and about some of the ideas that might
might be be brought to bear on it and i.
I remember at that stage i think
it was graham dunstan was saying
that they both of them were attracted
to the area around mullumbimby
but for various reasons. It
may not. May not occur there.
But that general region which i forget
who coined the word road by region
but it was that region that
we we were talking about.
And i can remember advancing.
The idea since of.
Working to try
and have a larger agenda for the festival
to help to with the decentralization
movement because i had just done a job
for the department of decentralisation
through the university of new england
about a town called mcclain.
Where i'd had a lot of contact
with local townspeople
and also farmers from the district and
they were very sad about the fact
that their kids were leaving
home and going to the city
and not continuing the rural tradition.
And the townspeople were also very
keen to attract. Development.
They will looking at their town declining
and the population declining and.
They were very worried
about about the future
and what i was therefore was to help
sort of plan a strategy for the future.
So this was very conscious
of that and i remember.
Relating this to john in graeme saying
that. There was this problem of.
Of a concentration of population
moving to the big cities
and the rural areas hadn't
been able to attract either.
New settlements or business
like or new rural developments
and it was a known fact
that the north coast.
In particular the dairy
industry was declining
and no matter how much funding the department
a decentralized asian injected into
it didn't seem to address that decline.
So i mean we were trying to look at a
bigger picture as well as having a festival
and enjoying the fruits of that.
And it was also from a from my point of
view university involvement it was a great
time to try some experiments
and to see what would work.
Well. I can remember being in them but.
Being in. I think we in lismore
we met up at least more
and i think it was tom's
a brisk he had a car
and there were four of us there including
tom and graham and john in the self
and i think we were cruising the area
looking for inspiration and sites
and i think graham in
particular was very keen.
Finding something like a wilderness
area like a wonderful place to be into
and to have a festival
and to be in a fairly unfettered
way try out a lot of new systems
and so i suppose we were
looking for a special site.
I mean none of us would talk seriously
about recycling a town at that stage.
And i remember when we first
sight of the nimbin rocks.
It was such a powerful impact that
everybody just said you know. Wow.
This has to be the site
somewhere around here
and i think the first instinct was to say
let's have a festival at the foothills of
the rocks.
Not knowing if it's
aboriginal significance
or anything else other than the fact
there was just a very powerful place
that we continued on and to
explore. You know around.
Around the place and then we found
that when we came into the town
and it was a village it was. It was. Worse
than mcclane in a sense in that it it.
There's almost a mint condition there only
to village with there's only one shop
alive. Very little action in the
streets and hardly anyone around
and i can recall then saying this.
This is the place
and i suppose i mean it was the connection
between this almost a film set village
and the membrane rocks
that created that sort of.
The notion that. Yeah we'd found the place
and now we should sort of
concentrate on what to do with it.
I think what the sequence
events after that was basically
that one of the things
that having just done the town exercise
was very conscious of participating with
local people. And i did suggest
that before we did too much else we
should have a meeting with the town
and set up a meeting
and start to negotiate whether in fact
the town people wanted just here he way.
But i felt sure they would because
of that background of. Involving.
And wanting to involve young
people in in rural values
and the opportunity to start new lives
i mean i think that the townspeople
and the organizers of the conference
had had a lot of common ground.
And i actually wasn't there when
that when those meetings occurred.
I had i went off to china.
For a educational visit.
Now in our meetings before i went though
we did talk about whether it should be a
wilderness site.
Or whether it should be what i was opting
for which was a degraded site like the
place where the impact of having x thousand
number of people for a couple of weeks
wouldn't. Wouldn't destroy
the site and i mean i was.
Very conscious of the fact
that the impact having been to other
events like that. I mean.
I don't remember and several others i
was aware that you know there was a.
There was a terrific potential
impact of so many people.
And the idea of finding sites close to the
town to sort of close to the village to
breathe life into the place and the fact
that there was already a transport
connection to lismore there was already some
what's a vacant shops and one shop
but there were facilities there
that could very could i add
the idea of a festival
and without having to put all the expensive
infrastructure because there was a
budgetary problem anyway about bringing
in water and handling transport
and also controlling it. I
mean as a police station.
If they're not that that was a factor
but it was a hospital and things like
that which were in the event were you
know useful things to have around.
So.
It more or less that all down
that you know we wouldn't go
over the rocks at them in rocks.
I don't think that site was
made available anyway.
And i don't know i didn't pursue.
As to whether we could use that site
but we did talk very seriously with the
owners of the sites closest to the main
street of nimbin one of whom acquiesced
to to letting us use the site
and the other one didn't.
So most of our planning work was
concentrated on the site where the festival
actually occurred.
And the idea of the street being part of
the the festival was actually endorsed by
the by the local. The local people.
You know. The time. Sure.
The general idea of
recycling was very strong.
I mean we were talking about
recycling all sorts of things.
I mean no one of the actually jumped
the scale up to recycling a town but.
I mean it was a natural extension
of recycling waste materials
or we saw recycling building
materials or recycling anything.
I mean rather than putting
energy into new products.
I mean that was very much
part of the ideology and
that found form in the idea of recycling
a town and not building a lot of stuff
that was already there.
There was a lot of interest in things
like solar energy i mean what.
What in fact is probably now one of the
centres of some who see this is found its
place in them and.
There was a lot of the stuff that
came out of the whole earth catalog
and the thinking that came out of there.
People were very anxious to explore like
building their own structures minimally.
And in fact you know it was a venue.
Most people who came there came with the
idea of building new sorts of structures.
Also ideas about using waste.
Methane to gestures and things like that.
To handle sewage and other
sort of waste water.
There was intense interest in
vegetarianism and new ways of of cooking
and also in.
Eating different sort of products starting
there was a growing interest in soybeans
and.
Many things like that goat's
cheeses and. And also in fruit.
You know there was it was no accident.
People used to say people went round
there with banana grins on their faces.
And it's no accident. Also that the
rainbow cafe started up as sort of a.
Very all you know a challenging
sort of food venue that.
And peeled a lot of people specially was
opposite the hotel i mean there was a
there was a mainstream culture going on
one side of the street with hamburgers
and beer and there was another culture
dead opposite going for soya burgers
and green tea and things like
that. But from my point of view.
I mean i was i'm a
planner and an architect
and i was very interested in my students
and ourselves being involved in in
designing and constructing the facilities.
So we actually our part of
the idea was to design.
And designate the camping areas and
the commune and the facilities areas
and the systems which would at least maintain
several thousand people for a couple
of couple of weeks and we did that
and i am especially was the sort
of was our client in that regard.
I mean he was the one who basically either
endorse the ideas or challenge them and.
And you know we did other things
but we did have a lot of contact.
I remember with the army when they were
extremely helpful in in how to handle
that many people on on frail sites
and we also had a lot of contact with
the state emergency services in lismore
and we had many many meetings with
the local with the shire council.
Because ultimately i suppose they
and the state emergency service
and the army if it was necessary might
have gotten involved somewhere along the
line. But as far as the services were
concerned. They had a health priority.
And the responsibility for health
and we we were conscious of that.
So we did opt for toilets
as being the best option.
And we had the local
lectures to authority come
and dig dig they did post holes
basically but in the sense
that pit toilets act.
Only was a sort of crude way of recycling
sewage because wherever the pit toilets
where we had planned an
orchard to take its place.
What was revolutionary i think
was that the pit toilets were.
Were community all and they
were sex they were sexless too
and i mean the one of
my during memories is.
A group of people sitting in a circle.
Having a crap and having a good time.
If you got extraordinarily and
i mean the things like privacy
and modesty just were
blown out the window.
I must say that when we planned that we
did have we did have them in circles
that we had a bit of privacy
enforced. The camping areas.
I mean the priority was given to committee
facilities like there was a health like
a hospital place for emergencies.
There were places where cooking was done
and where there was access
to the creek water.
The sites for the camping were
well away from the creek.
We're very conscious of the
fact that people could.
You know pollute the
groundwater very easily.
So where the where the pitch were dug also
real careful not to penetrate the water
table and it would have contributed.
And we used a lot of cheap materials
like parachutes and poles and.
Like the the toilets themselves were just
hessian and posts and pits and we did.
Hire pans that came in.
All those squatting toilets were very
fashionable into we we did a lot of we built
a lot of. Footprint type squatting
toilets. So when you went to the toilet.
You had an option of a squatter or a pan.
The water system we just basically we did
collect water of rooms where we we could
do it but we relied on town
water and also the creek. The.
Gray water.
From cooking and other places was
put into salix pits that day
and the the general planning of the of
the festival designated parking areas
and places where people like checkpoints
so people when they came into town
or came out of the camping sites.
You know had entrance fees and things like
that. These.
Tepees were very interesting.
I mean a lot of people would normally
surmount of effort into their like was almost
like a display village of g-d
domes tepees recycled a lot of
bamboo because people found
bamboo in the region
and they persuaded some farmers to let them
have a lot of natural materials people
did earth brick construction.
The favored materials were
natural materials means to say
or recycle materials like people
building things out of our member. One.
Dear d extractor was build out of.
I think it's starting to many
a bit of something like that
that the northern star throughout
all these printing plates
and someone found a use where they could
actually. Tip of the gather they had a.
Unusual looking judy's extraction.
But one tenth of course and
caravans we all structures
but the most extraordinary ones i think
were enormous spans done in bamboo using
geodesic principles. There.
One of the things
that the army helped us with so was they
set us up with might have been emergency
services set us up with a telephone
wireless telephone system.
Which and some of the students
got involved in being more
or less like like a foreman is on.
Building job and there was
a couple of really good.
Women students that started to do
all of that sort of on site workers
and the students who were deployed
into you know various work teams and.
I think i haven't. I do remember now was.
I think there was a very
low ebb like graeme
and a number of supporters had moved
into name but and the living there.
And i recall that they were i'd heard
that they are very sad because they didn't
think anything was going to happen no
one of the right on the side no one.
And then we all went up on a on a big
bus like a whole load of us we had a 80
seater bus. And we arrived at
neiman in the middle of the night.
But it wasn't middle of the night
it was about. The dinner time.
And we just arrived in the main
street of nimbin and graeme
and a few other people were eating in
the daisies cafe which was the one
that was just certainly this injection of
energy like just the numbers of people
who are enthusiastic and committed and
that sort of you know things
just started to fire from there.
So we moved onto the sites
and started work and.
That must have been about i don't know
four weeks or so before the thing started.
But. I mean it was good. Good for
students good for us and the systems.
You know they were primitive but they
worked and there were no health outbreaks.
There were health problems
people did get sick.
And there were there were some problems
but they weren't messes i mean
coping with that amount of people
and the council were basically happy
and the emergency stardom urgency people
didn't get involved the army would call in
the coppers paid a few visits
but generally speaking the
place worked except i mean.
A lot of people were experimenting with.
Knocking down a lot of inhibitions
and whilst the townspeople had welcomed
the idea when the actual thing occurred.
I mean they were confronted
with extraordinary.
Assault on their senses and on their
ideas about modesty and privacy
and drug use and all sorts of things.
I mean it was just extraordinary
the the battering that.
I think but they got what
they wanted. Basically they.
They got thousands of people they had
an incredible injection of funds
and energy and into the place and.
After first it was over i was
involved in setting up the afternoon
and what meetings.
Because we had been we had realised
during the course the festival
that you know a lot of people are
getting very committed to staying there
and we're quite anxious to try and
purchase some key properties to.
To make sure
that we you know we weren't going to get
done over by the real estate people in the
area and some people didn't.
I mean the tomato sauce filling was a card
and there were some other props
the rainbow cafe and things like
that were required and i think
and carnival falls was a call so.
That's really where terry mcgarry
though came to prominence. I mean he.
Who gradually took over those meetings
and the running really was all the
people when whilst. As a planner.
I was interested in the
afternoon but what idea
and certainly wanted to help facilitate
what i got into the thing believing
that you know he was something
that decentralize it was actually
decentralization it was happening.
It was about lifestyle it wasn't
about industry or anything else.
It was about people wanting a different
life. But the people who. Who.
I formed the core groups out of the
afternoon the what meetings actually.
With a core group that then
purchase tangible falls and.
And set up the robo cafe
and started tomato sauce as
a sort of a drop in centre
and then eventually got
involved in the schooling and.
The birthing center and the
media center and i mean it.
You know even what is what is now.
Oh yeah i just i mean at the time i was
living with a bunch of other people in
castle cragg right on the waterfront.
I mean it was it took half an hour to get
there because there was a 200 foot cliff
you had to climb up and down and it was
one of those sort of left over places
but no idea like.
I mean i had found nothing that would
have compared with the lifestyle there.
I mean we had a wonderful time we had.
Canoeing and we had a pearl
and we had our own gardens
and as far as i was concerned we were
doing it anyway but i must say that
when my mother died which is around that
time i inherited a little bit of money
and i went off and i bought a property
on the hawkesbury river which was.
I mean that was my move to decentralize
and i guess a lot of people worried
about nuclear war and things like that
and i was certainly very
interested in autonomy.
And there's two things
i did one was to set.
I found a derelict old house on the
hawkesbury which i've got students involved
and we've we had a commune there and we
actually started to fix up the house
and the gardens and that move
towards self-sufficiency
and i still in.
Your teaching
and one of the things we did at the university
was build the thomas house which is
built entirely out of recycled
materials and that had solar hot water
and it had a solar a conditioning
system and the methane the jester
and associated gardens
and several of the students lived
there for four years only university.
Wanted to get rid of it
and when it benefits
that we get it up in the first place
that it's lasted for four years.
Let it wind generators i mean
it was an extraordinary sight
on a on a campus.
That was full of brick
and concrete buildings to find this what
the vice-chancellor call the federal house
set in this derelict bit of ground
that actually started to turn
into these wonderful gardens
and we had four fairs which were
free and people used to come in
and display what they you know anything
that was alternative was a was fair game.
And that's where bill mollison started.
I mean he came to the other first venues
that he got involved in the lots
of aboriginal groups and g-d.
Tony eady put up an enormous
g-d extraction that.
We're course we experimented with
recycling systems and solar energy
and villages and a lot of
gardeners got involved
and universe if you south wales come over
and built a mud brick
oven brian would would.
I mean it was that it was a became
a focal point for a lot of.
Mclay sheen had a solar cooker and
that lots of i mean it became
a place where people could.
You know show their ideas to other people
and before fairs were
really very very successful
when we ran out of gas after fortunate.
There was nothing more we could say i
suppose but also we got a bit worried
when the people who are involved
in setting up the house that. He.
We were setting up an absolute.
Autonomous system within
the middle of a huge city
that had all these systems in place
and we thought it was a bit bit of an
anachronism actually do a good tour
and what we came to conclusion that it
wasn't the systems wasn't the location
and it wasn't going to nimbin or the
hawkesbury river or castle cragg
or anything else.
What was fundamental to what we're on
about was actually a change of attitude
and a change of personal lifestyle
and a commitment to. You know.
Being aware globally and acting locally.
You know that slogan was around the time.
And it didn't matter whether i mean
we didn't think it was mattered
that we weren't living it
nimbin or anywhere else.
The fact was that we were
challenging the system
and we were being personally
responsible for what we did.
And we're altering our lifestyle that
we've been conscious about not wasting
and we were conscious about
not trying things out.
And we were committed to working on
systems and ways of building that.
You know what you've
now cause sustainable.
So i used to get a bit pissed off
that the ideas were.
When our ideas
or what we thought we're how it is
i mean probably weren't our ideas
but anyway we own them.
We got a bit disturbed the way mainstream
culture sometimes adapted them.
I mean a classic point was we've done a lot
of work on solar water collectors with
a guy called michael ling who had a
fascinating idea about parabolic reflectors
and we set up you know. A cheap
recycled version of that.
And then along comes a solar heart.
And they they produce a system which
we fought thought was really inferior.
I mean it was using materials that
weren't that weren't energy efficient.
Whereas they've been firms like beazley for
example south australia had been doing
so i water systems for years.
I mean they've been up in the 1930s
for you know had never caught on.
But solar heart went ahead.
Like gangbusters and they
produced these heavy systems
that sat on rooms where they and
they worked and. The public.
Bought them and they feel good about them.
I mean i don't think they alter
their lifestyle one inch though
and they still continue to use
more water than they had to.
And they still had an
electric backup system.
So you know i did feel a bit upset about
that but i don't now i just think
that.
Those ideas of most of the ideas
that were being experimented with have
been adopted by mainstream culture and.
And that's good. I mean.
I don't think lifestyle has been altered
materially it's still a very consumers
society but that may
change or is changing.
I mean there were a lot of the green movements
now which probably had their origins
then. And it was almost a
religion became a religion.
I mean.
Those values of permeating at every level
and i think the federal government
and other people in places like the water
board and planning authorities and.
In in local government and in a
very conscious of these values now.
When it was unheard of for example.
10 years ago to actually
have citizens recycling the.
Their their products of
their waste products.
At a local government level
and i remember going out of the
city council arguing black and blue
that they should start a paper recycling
program and they just said are you mad.
You know. You know just doesn't work it's
not economic. It's cost but over time.
It's become absolutely essential.
No council would dare not recycle
when you zealanders got into
it long before australians.
When they had some wonderful
recycling programs.
But i mean there are things
like that that i'm very pleased
that they've become mainstream.
I mean i suppose in some ways.
This rampant sort of
consumerism is going to.
Mean people are now aware much more they
ever were about the finite resources of
the planet and are being a lot more
more careful about what they do.
We're still hooked on a lot of
things like our transport systems.
But there i mean there are people
like better cities program
that are conscientious lee trying to get
people out of their cars they try to
locate workplaces close to living places
or to integrate them. There are people.
Pushing light rail their
people pushing better water
systems or recycling water's
stormwater and cleaning it
and recycling the housing
department believe it
or not is now putting in twin water systems
in their houses on the outer suburbs.
Because i mean every site
live got two systems of water
and they're ever conscious that
they're polluting the hawks.
So i mean i am very happy about all that.
It's maybe not moving fast enough
and maybe not being conclusive enough by
big disappointment is i guess lifestyle
and i still think that's i've come to believe
that's the issue. And unless you can.
Right through to people that are
very at their household level.
Which is one reason why for example at
the moment i'm interested in a recycling
sewage system that actually started the
household starts and finishes the house
and when i think basically people are
more responsible than bureaucracies
and people are very seemed to me to be
very willing to allow bureau bureaucracies
to do the dirty work and
then criticize them for it
but if it was sheeted home at a household
level about that's where it really
matters then. Just as. Just as.
The community have been capable
of handling the recycling. Idea.
I think they could take on
just take it one step further
and now start looking at their water
supply their stormwater their grey water
and their sewage.
There's another thing i want to add which
i perhaps should have said some time ago
but that is after the festival was over.
Johnny allen
and i went to see the department
decentralisation because we thought you know.
We've done it
and they haven't you know here's these
thousands of people living up there and.
And so we went to see them
and said look you know we think we've
got a better formula than you have.
And it's all about lost time.
And they they sort of they said they
were interested because they'd heard
and seen the phenomenon.
But they weren't at all
impressed with the people
or you know they just thought you know
how we're not going to flood the country
with hippies. Even though i mean.
Lots of the
but the kids at neiman i mean one of the
best experiences i had there was this.
This family have said you
know my kids came back.
You know with that festival and i thought
that was that was good. For the.
Family that was really quite a success
that in fact their kids had returned
because they they came back with.
Attitudes that their parents
probably didn't like
but nevertheless they were back and
they were going to do organic farming
and they were going to tell their old
man to get rid of the pesticides
and the fertilizer and to wake up and
but that was the that was the challenge
and they came back on their own terms
not on their own their parents terms.
But this it was asian didn't give us a
lot of money to go and do it again so.
But it happened anyway when people
started settling in bieber valley
and in new england area and.
When i was party to setting up a
huge community coffs harbour.
We had 200 shareholders and.
We bought a wonderful piece of land
on the waterfront of some badger.
And i'm still a member of
that but i i don't go there.
Person that set
that up was an insurance salesman actually
i just i can never i i think he actually
i mean he was committed to the ideology
and lifestyle but underneath it all.
He was actually selling an insurance
policy and people bought it and
when they said you know here's the
lifeboats. You know if things get crook.
We'll go. We'll go north.
Well i was delighted. I mean i was a
lot of the people stayed and i was.
I've been back to nimbin a couple
of times since the festival.
Three times four times i
think and i'm very proud
that i was part of the the idea to breathe
some life in an embed i mean i very
proud. I mean i think
it. I think it worked.
It went through a lot of
teething problems of.
It's a lot of conflict
and it was very painful for a lot of
people to confront that sort of lifestyle
and to have their lives disrupted
in that way but in the end.
I think that both the people who settled
there and the people who live there.
Well people who went there 20 years ago
have now become the establishment.
I mean the last time was up hours.
I was a bit disturbed
that the people who are speaking
to go there now the minority
and they were called the droogs of the old
established hippies were becoming the
sort of like the establishment
when. It's like recycling.
But a lot of them have still got
their are their ideals and.
I got involved in a you know what's called
a development control plan with some of
the residents
and we did run some workshops about what
direction the town wanted to go in and.
Lismore council amazingly were
prepared to pass over a lot of the
responsibility for preparing master plans
over to you know a community committee.
Of very responsible.
You know active people and they did it
and i was just a facilitator
from outside it came in
and sort of you know helped
if a technical point of view
but i was also pleased about that.
I mean he was citizens getting up
and taking control of the
town the way it ought to be.
Instead of continually relying on the
council to do things or i mean it's
that thing of acting locally and
and not not passing responsibility down
the line and then getting upset about it.
Just.
I'm i say in my day to day operations in
i'm very i'm committed to housing i mean
i'm more and more involved in.
In community based housing and
with and in aboriginal work.
I've been working for 20 years
with a housing company.
And i continually run into
people in the bureaucracy
or in in powerful positions in
government who i used to know
20 years ago less
but who i knew you know had been attracted
to the same sort of things i have been
attracted to and. In some ways
they still had constraints
but a lot of them still had
a lot of that ideology
and the best thing about it was that
you could talk. I could talk to them.
From a point of view that where
we both knew who had come from.
And one could appeal to some of
their earlier instincts and.
And sometimes get to a position where we
couldn't have got two had we not known
each other or had i not known
that they'd been there
and put a bureaucratic facade and
there are a lot of people like that.
With a lot of goodwill in government in the
public service who are actually trying
to. Still do things that
are important to people
and still reflect empowering
local people and.
In gendering some idea of cooperation.
The article i read in this morning's paper
are still saying communes in co-ops were
one of the sort of
hallmarks that might be so
but i mean co-op is you've been around in
the in the dairy company for four years i
mean they were birthed in about the 1920s
in effect the cult movement got its got
its start in the very dairy
industry in the north coast
and it's not it's not a big shift to switch
to housing cooperatives is not a happy
thing. At all. It makes a lot of sense
and i'm particularly committed to housing
co-op is a there's a bridge between
rental and home ownership and.
In working with aboriginal communities
i mean they were they were exploring
and developing community. Communes
and community lifestyles and.
Tribal lifestyles you know so
that hundreds of thousands of years probably
where that's where the co-operative
movement in the probably got its
origins out of tribal cultures
and it's interesting that the
aboriginal communities around.
Lismore actually were a vital part
of the aquarius festival as well
when they they were there in
numbers and they participated and.
That was quite a strong
part of the festival
and the housing property movement is
probably in aboriginal circles is one of the
strongest movements in the.
In the state of hundreds of housing
co-ops in new south wales and queensland.
And they continue to.
To develop on cooperative principles.
Yeah i don't know the land rights issue was
canvassed at the at the festival issues
of commute ality and lifestyle and
like some of the aboriginal people
that came to that festival.
Talked about the students
as white aboriginals
like they they their
perception was that a lot of.
The alternative culture was in fact
experimenting with an aboriginal lifestyle.
Like having a little impact on the
land eating more natural materials
and acting and entertaining.
Skills in a very aboriginal sort
of way like dancing and singing
and campfire sort of culture was.
Was very evident and
people like harry penrith.
And mike she got there lots of people
who either aboriginal people are well
connected in a bundle and mob.
Gary and williams.
I mean it all had gotten involved
and who had a powerful influence i
think in a lot of the thinking.
Burn and burn it. That's how it
was used to call her parents.
I mean he was
and has been continuously involved in an
alternative lifestyle sort of movement
and in trying to connect white australians
with a sort of a tribal culture.